now the midterm elections are around the
corner 18 days from right now and the
central question remaining isn't just
who will win Congress whether the
Democratic Party will remain a
legitimate political organization or
become something else entirely
elements of the Democratic coalition are
becoming radical some are threatening
violence and we're advocating violence
others are taking the next step and
engaging in violence even the party's
leaders those with the deepest ties to
the establishment and the most to lose
are suddenly saying things that would
have been unimaginable just a year ago
here for example is Nancy Pelosi watch
her explain that people will be hurt in
order to achieve the Democratic Party's
goals and that's okay watch we have to
have total clarity about what we do when
it comes to everything a woman's right
to choose by just about immigration
whether it's about gun safety or there's
about climate we didn't talk about
climate and if there's some collateral
damage for some others who do not share
our view well so be it
collateral damage she's talking about
you you're collateral damage in policies
remarkably directs calculation thanks
for telling us you're one of those
people in the way you're an
inconvenience we'll be crushed beneath
the wheels of progress when it comes
right down to it we are one of those
infamous eggs that must be broken to
make the world's greatest omelet just
today by the way a New York man called
Ronald DC was charged for threatening
senators Chuck Grassley and Susan
Collins with death why because they
dared to support the Brett Kavanaugh
nomination they were in the way so did
the woman in this video she was in the
way too she made the mistake of wearing
an NYPD hat in the presence of a leftist
watch what happened when she did why are
you trying to block me I'm trying to
walk here
idiot
I'm not your boyfriend or your
sodomizing immigrants with their bully
sticks so yeah you're the great I'm glad
your husband died in 9/11 says a
representative of the youth wing of the
Democratic Party and Coulter from
watching moments like these for the past
three years and writing about them our
new book is called resistance is futile
how the Trump aiding left lost its
collective mind and she joins us tonight
in studio Anna's great to see you thank
you good to be so what does the
Democratic Party look like nineteen days
from now how do they put this all back
together they've gone they showed us who
they are what are they when the smoke
clears I wouldn't judge how they do this
fall by assume that these comments are
beloved by the people I mean I think
people have to remember a blue wave is
the historic norm right yeah it's very
possible they'll take control of the
house luckily and I think a lot because
of some of the things you just showed
and of course the reaction to justice
Cavanaugh
it doesn't look like they're going to
take the US Senate but they they ought
to be having a huge blue wave and they
probably won't have it because of
because they're insane they've gone mad
but the people run the party who are
vested and the people who hold office or
who you know whose livelihoods depends
on the Democratic Party I mean they must
be getting nervous because they can't
control their base um no they do this
all the time I mean they did it after
Ferguson in order to help the Democrats
win an election they are willing to gin
up race hatred as they did after what
happened in Ferguson they're willing at
this point after Kavanagh and continuing
is over the election to gin up mentally
ill women and they can't control them I
mean once they've done it they just walk
away and you have I mean you've seen the
statistics on the Ferguson effect
written about by by Heather McDonald
among others that the black the rate of
blacks being murder
went up astronomically after Ferguson
and particularly in cities where there
was an alleged police racist shooting
incidentally I've noticed that police
suddenly stopped engaging in racist
attacks on on black people once they
started wearing body cameras you notice
how they find they just sort of went
away I did notice the ACLU was actually
suing some cities to make them stop
wearing body because they keep getting
caught making false allegations of a
racist cop as a Princeton woman did a
Princeton professor made a false
allegation of a cop racist stop and haha
there was a body camera under a complete
lie does the Democratic Party ever
become the Democratic Party of 2012 or
1998 or kind of a party concerned with
you know economics and something other
than identity politics it doesn't look
like it there was an interesting article
um you won't hear these words come out
of my mouth very often in the New York
Times this week by Thomas Edsel breaking
down all of these polls on how the
Democratic Party has changed and it is
I'm just noticed looking at Earth
remembered it looking at Nancy Pelosi
white liberal women have just gone off
the charts on on left-wing craziness and
it has nothing to do with economics the
Democratic Party as some of us kind of
noticed during the Clinton era that was
when it was began during the Clinton era
just abandoned the working class
abandoned the flyover people it is
pedal-to-the-metal on identity politics
and and you know the yuppie lifestyle is
basic the marsh and Marin and George
yuppies and welfare recipients that's a
not exactly that's never been put more
personally or truly Ann Coulter thank
you resistance is futile is her
excellent book thank you